i guess the misconception that like
snowfall is like directly about you even
though they didn't
they couldn't say that because they
didn't drop the bag off that they should
have probably dropped the bag off for
you but they might be getting ready to
drop it now you know i got the phone
call they want to they want to sit down
they want to sit down
in terms of what though i don't know
in terms of like bringing you into the
fold you just told me they want me to
come to the studio
what are we going to talk about i don't
even know the snowfall producers or the
network or
the show i mean obviously john singleton
passed away rest in peace they said he
said he was a producer
i mean but it's it has to do with
snowfall or is it separate no there's
snowfall
i mean
i mean because i mean listen
anyone who's familiar with your story i
mean like well they know they changed
commercials when when they add the first
commercials on snowfall my fans gave
them the blues
hashtag and john singleton snowfall i
mean fx all of them hey this is rick's
story y'all stole rick story yeah i mean
obviously it's not the same
because then that then you could sue the
living [ __ ] out of them
have did you try to sue
no i thought about it i talked to a few
lawyers it it's it's a tough suit
it is a tough it can be one it's a tough
lawsuit it's a tough lawsuit um intimate
domain you know i got so much stuff in
newspapers
right right right right so so if you
think about like the show uh
i i mean
as far as the first season i guess
like i guess
how much of that do you feel like was
really i didn't watch it you didn't
watch it okay i i only start watching
the show after i got the call from dave
and he wanted me to come be a part of
his podcast uh after the snow before
that i never watched snowfall i i
probably had glanced you know passing by
in in
and seeing it on tv now i did have
dinner uh lunch with franklin before i
was at whole foods downtown with the
actor yeah the english guy uh something
idris is his name i forget his first
name yeah i don't know his name but uh
it seems like i'm terrible with names
seems like a nice guy
very nice guy i like him so you guys had
dinner
lunch lunch you guys had lunch did he
like try to pick your brain or or no how
was that combo
i was sitting there because i didn't
know who he was okay because you're like
i don't even watch the [ __ ] show i
don't watch the show how would i know
who you are you know and he walked up
and he was like you mr ross and i was
like yeah
and uh
my managers were sitting there and they
was like
that's the guy from snowfall and i was
like what
and i was like sit down you sit down so
he sit down and we just started talking
he was like man i don't know why johnny
got you on the set and
i would do a much better job if i had
you around and you know we just went
through the little thing you know he
probably was blowing a little smoke too
you know of course
of course he runs into u.s
so but it was a cool conversation uh um
and and you know we just got after we
finished eating we just got up and we we
went our separate ways